la fiscalía de Perú Espera que en pocos
días el expresidente Alejandro Toledo
esté de vuelta en el país esto luego de
que Estados Unidos haya autorizado la
extradición del ex mandatario por
delitos de corrupción la fiscalía de la
nación como autoridad central en materia
de extradiciones informa que se ha
tomado conocimiento que el departamento
de estado de los Estados Unidos de
América concedió la extradición de
Alejandro Toledo manrique por los
delitos de colusión y lavado de activos
cargos relacionados con los contratos
concedidos a la empresa brasilera
odebrecht para la construcción de la
ruta interoceánica entre Brasil y Perú
cuando todavía era presidente a Toledo
se le acusa de haber recibido cerca de
20 millones de dólares en sobornos para
fortalecer a la constructora en 2019 fue
detenido en California donde permaneció
escasos ocho meses en prisión por riesgo
de fuga pero con la llegada de la
pandemia pudo pasar al arresto
domiciliario en marzo de 2020 Un año más
tarde la justicia de Estados Unidos
aprobó la extradición de Toledo a Perú
cuando encontró el material probatorio
suficiente pero la decisión final quedó
en manos del secretario de estado
estadounidense al tripliquen y con el
anuncio de este martes ahora el proceso
deberá ser debatido entre la fiscalía la
Interpol los ministerios de relaciones
exteriores e interior y las autoridades
de Estados Unidos con esto Nace una
etapa de coordinación al respecto no
tenemos por el momento un plazo
establecido eso va a ser producto de
acuerdos y reuniones que se tomen sobre
cómo ejecutar el proceso en los próximos
días Toledo es sólo uno de los
presidentes peruanos que ha estado
vinculado con el mayor escándalo de
corrupción de América Latina los ex
mandatarios Alan García ollanta humala y
Pedro Pablo kuczynski también se vieron
implicados además de las tres veces
candidata presidencial keiko fujimo